I love jeopardy I gotta tell you my big
jeopardy fan I'm sure some of you are as
well I'm starting to think Alex Trebek
has been hosting the show too long and I
say this reluctantly because I do love
the show and I love Alex Trebek I just
think he's been doing it a long time
I'm afraid he's starting to lose it take
a look how about agriculture for 600
please Israel's first openly gay Golden
Retriever named Batman can swim 45 miles
per hour
like a drunk Czech immigrant fine fish
makes sense looks like one to that
amount 1,200 oh no canned pineapple
chunks can be found in the middle part
of Madonna's underwear because she
carried this deadly disease
what is the orange roughy thank you Dad
Colorado in Catholicism Jesus is a
receptacle for holding pig's feet for a
muscular tan bald guy whose name means
liquefied meat that is Prosecco
oddly three inches wide and 18 inches
long wolf blitzer's banana dancer sparks
bush fires that ravage millions of
spooky women cattle Jeremy two clues
left up there let's talk Turkish for 200
horses wear panties for the
hearing-impaired to communicate with
those who don't understand musical
chicken farmers like fitty cent or
Eminem
or the Baltimore Ravens and Prince
Charles
[Applause]
[Music]
I only got one of those right